- [Instructor] What we're
gonna do in this video
is get a little bit more practice
constructing Lewis diagrams,
and in particular, we're going to try
to construct the Lewis
diagram for formaldehyde.
Formaldehyde has one
carbon, two hydrogens,
and an oxygen, CH2O.
So pause this video and have a go at it.
Try to construct a valid Lewis structure,
or a Lewis diagram for formaldehyde.
All right, now let's do this together.
Now the first step, and we
saw this in a previous video,
we want to think about all
of the valence electrons
for this molecule.
So we want to account,
account for the valence electrons.
Now the reason why we wanna do that
is so that while we're trying
to create this structure,
we are making use of all
of the valence electrons.
And to figure out how many
total valence electrons we have,
we can look at a periodic
table of elements.
We can see that carbon,
it's in that second row,
in that second period,
so its second shell is its outer shell.
And in that shell,
it has one, two, three,
four valence electrons.
So, carbon has four valence electrons.
A neutral free hydrogen atom
is going to have one valence electron,
but we have two of them here,
so it's gonna be two times one.
And then, oxygen, it also
is in the second period,
and in its second shell
it has one, two, three, four,
five, six valence electrons.
And so the total valence
electrons in this molecule
are gonna be four plus two,
which is six, plus six,
which is equal to 12 valence electrons.
Now the next step is to
try to draw a structure.
Try to draw,
draw single bonds, I'll say, single bonds.
And a key question is,
what do we think is going
to be our central atom?
And the rule of thumb is the
least electronegative atom,
that is not hydrogen,
is a good candidate for our central atom.
So we can rule out hydrogen.
So between carbon and
oxygen, we know that oxygen
is one of the most electronegative atoms,
well one of the most
electronegative elements
on the periodic table of elements.
It's very close to fluorine.
And so carbon is a good
candidate for the central atom.
So let's put the carbon right over here,
and then let's put these
other atoms around it.
We could call them terminal atoms.
So, let's put our oxygen right over there,
and then we have two hydrogens.
Hydrogen there, a hydrogen there.
And let me draw the bonds.
So that's a single bond.
That accounts for two valence electrons.
So I've just used two,
four, six valence electrons.
So if I subtract six valence electrons,
I am now left with six valence electrons,
six valence electrons.
So the next step is
allocate the remaining valence electrons,
trying to get to the octet rule
for atoms that are not
hydrogen, and then for hydrogen,
trying to get it to have
two valence electrons.
So allocate, allocate the remaining,
remaining valence electrons.
All right, so let's
start with this oxygen.
This oxygen already
has these two electrons
that it's sharing hanging around.
So in order to get to the
octet rule, it needs six more.
So let's give it six electrons.
So, one, two, three, four, five, six.
Well I've just used up the
remaining six valence electrons.
So I don't really have
any more to play with,
but let's see how the
other atoms are feeling.
So hydrogen here, it's able
to share these two electrons
that are in this covalent
bond, so it's feeling good.
It can kind of pretend that
it has a full outer shell,
'cause its outer shell is just that one,
that first shell, that's
filled with two electrons.
Same thing for this other hydrogen.
So at least the terminal atoms,
the oxygen and the two hydrogens,
are feeling like they
have a full outer shell.
But then in the fourth step,
we're going to look at our central atom.
So, let's focus on the
central atom, central atom,
and do we need more bonds,
or do we need to do
something interesting here?
And what we see is that carbon,
it's able to have two, four, six electrons
hanging around it, but it
would love to have eight.
Carbon would love to
have a full outer shell,
so how could we do that?
Well, we could add more bonds.
Where could the bonds come from?
Well it would come from
some lone pair of electrons.
Well the only lone pairs of electrons
are hanging around this oxygen.
So what if we were to take,
say, this lone pair of electrons,
and then construct another
covalent bond with that?
Then, our Lewis diagram
will look like this.
I will actually redraw it.
So you have your carbon,
you have your three
original covalent bonds,
you had a hydrogen, a hydrogen,
and then you had your
oxygen, right over here,
and now we've formed a new
covalent bond, just like this,
and then you have these
two other lone pairs
around the oxygen.
So let me draw that.
So, two, then another
two around the oxygen.
And this is looking pretty
good, because the oxygen,
it still has eight
electrons hanging around,
four in lone pairs,
and then four, they're in this double bond
that it is sharing.
The hydrogens still have two
electrons hanging around.
They're able to share the electrons
in each of these covalent bonds.
And now the carbon is participating in,
you could think of it
as four covalent bonds,
two single bonds and one double bond,
so each of those have two
electrons associated with it,
so it has eight electrons hanging around.
So this is looking really good
as a legitimate Lewis structure,
or Lewis diagram for formaldehyde.